how's it going breasts - beer today I'm
here with the lovely cutie pie
Edgar today we're playing but sniffing
puns they are actually doing a veil for
us with Maya anchor so hopefully we'll
play that in the future you haven't
played this game before so oh yeah yes
you're right oh my god when they say
they would add more stuff but yeah
that's totally Maya you're right and
this is Edgar okay so I'll play the
Edgar the powers are random so to get a
different power we have to sniff each
other in the butt because it's blood
sniffing bugs
the game is just to explore pee or poop
you have bite and poop
I have bark and so you do different
things oh you got a fridge be cool I'll
I'll pee on the frisbee yeah
nice moustache yeah are you gonna poop
on the frisbee
I missed oh yeah foot prints be nice
just to explore once you find like all
the secrets you finish I know you can
activate a trampoline - there's like a
how dare she
oh my god the birds poop now but I know
there's something you can do with the
lady yeah so one of us has to like
distract her while the other one goes
and get okay catch mails back
yeah yeah take it what what are you
throwing that yeah I says when I get the
hot dog stand gonna bark at her not if
he in this bush come on later take the
sandwich eat the sandwich what we get
the trampoline scoot oh god I can scoot
now yeah yeah oh my god so cool let's do
a trick we go let's do a scoop but hard
oh my god that's the most prettiest part
I've ever seen okay
well I think there's here there's
definitely more stuff to explore
well that's fun sniffing pugs they're
gonna do a Kickstarter I I love this
game check to check it out when it comes
out supporting the Kickstarter when it
comes out because we obviously need more
button sniffing pug
okay thank you for joining me and we
will see then you're watching and we
will see you in the next video
charge your brofist can you stop hitting
me come on go ball go ball go ball oh
you're so bad